[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation I am
joining with my buddy Aron Alexander
today because we just covered the
Invincible season 2 trailer and we
covered Invincible season 1 together we
covered Invincible Adam Eve together so
he's my Invincible partner right here my
omn man if you will that's what people
call him around town it's a compliment
believe it or not anyway they released
this trailer for Mortal Kombat 1 and we
didn't do haven't done any of recover
from Mortal Kombat 1 I know some people
been like where's all recover we haven't
done it last time around it all got
yellow dollar bill signs we're going to
risk it today because ZN man first look
at this I just watched the combat pack
reveal trailer I skimmed it cuz I wanted
to see the image are you excited Aaron
oh my God I'm so excited I'm excited too
that was boring it's only one minute
long that's crazy I feel like you can
really bring like we'll talk more about
it after but I feel like there's a lot
of great
potential you have destroyed worlds I
have erased whole time timelines finally
a worthy challenge damn it looks so real
yeah
right you get actual JK
Simmons it sounds like
him wow oh
dude this kind of oh my God oh my God oh
dude look out of the show claim this
timeline for the bilum Empire you will
burn for the in it works in the story
line awesome
O Let's see it you going do the trade
you going do the trade
thing yes oh
oh that
perfect hell yeah wow he it works so so
seamlessly into Mortal Kombat yeah who
would have th I feel like he could
destroy everyone though oh he would
easily everybody on a narrative level he
would destroy
everyone on a Nar but Greg behind the
controller would I am so bad I love
playing Mortal Kombat I have I love
verse like I have friends where I just
verse them but I haven't actually played
through a story in ages uh but I when I
heard omn I'm like oh that's perfect
because it's one thing to take a real
life action character and they pulled it
off many times before and sometimes it
works better than others but when you
take a real life character or one from a
liveaction medium I mean and then you
place them into Mortal Kombat sometimes
aesthetically it looks cool but video
game wise it doesn't translate as well
but omn man is an animated character so
when you tell me he's going to be in
Mortal Kombat and like yeah that I feel
like you can definitely pull it off he's
already an animated character and you
can probably bring the motion the action
the flying the entire movement to life
and I think the thing that surprised me
about this visually was kind of the
odity of he's still animated but he
looks more photo realistic than when you
watch the Amazon Prime
show so had this like weird upgrade in
computer animation because he's supposed
to look more hum like he's not exactly
plucked out of the show because he looks
more real yeah he look like a real man
yeah so it's a little charring to me but
I love that because it still
distinguishes and separates it from the
animated uh its animated counterpart uh
but yeah what' you think man I thought
it was great no I couldn't agree with
you more I thought the the fact that it
seems like it sounds like JK Simmons
which is really cool and the fact that
they're using some of the same imagery
and some of the devastating things we
saw at the end of season one of the show
is is like such a cool callback and yeah
I couldn't agree more the fact that he
seamlessly fits into the show and even
the way he moves like granted you we've
had like guest characters in Mortal
Kombat before but something about the
way he moves even in the actual fighting
that's beyond the cut scenes just feels
so omn man it feels like that you feel
the the visceral nature of this this
Powerhouse and they have even some of
the his characteristics or like his uh
his lore into there and kind of how you
were saying it fits perfectly into the
the nature of this game cuz what isn't
Mortal Kombat in in and of itself like a
Multiverse kind of a tourn yeah and the
tournament of Realms yeah exactly uh
yeah I thought there was a lot of cool
very cool things and it's very violent
and the show's very violent and the
comic's very violent and the game is
very violent so it's like the perfect
marriage I'm EXC beautiful Union what
I'm looking forward to and and I wonder
if they got Anthony star to play him in
Mortal Kombat because you have the you
have homelander coming into this as well
yeah what's their dialogue like together
what are the dialogue scenes going to be
like back back and forth are going to
bring that dream to life I really feel
like I really feel like because specula
about this in our Invincible season 2
reaction that somehow they're going to
cross over Invincible in the boys I
think they're going to do it in some way
that would be so Co um but to see the
crossover happen in a video game format
where you're going to bring like the an
the the animation styles to make them
similar so they feel like they're in the
same universe you know so you're going
to get like two differences you're going
to get omn man who is very much an
animation character look a little bit
more photo realistic you're going to
take homelander who's a liveaction
character and make him look more
animated yeah then you're going to meet
them in the middle but their powers are
already so similar yeah you know so I'm
wondering how they can help distinguish
that in some capacity where you you
don't feel like you're just playing
someone with a different skin you know
it's not just like switching between
rayu and Ken I've upset someone who's
like actually rayu Ken is the exact
they're the exact same all right just
one's Japanese the other guy's white all
right they're the exact same but the but
it's like that's that is the one part of
it where I'm like I'm excited at the
prospect of seeing homelander and omn
man of course go be able to play against
each other I think it's really cool but
I do want to see what will make them
different ultimately um when you're
playing the game I think the the
interesting thing that I hope they would
bring to the game is that you know in
the universe of the boys no one's really
as strong as homelander so he never
really has to fight that much so I feel
like I hope his fighting looks like it's
taking like minimal effort because he's
like the strongest person strongest
being in that Universe right but you
know we'll we'll see what that what that
looks like I would just hope that when
they come to blows it's just such a
satisfying experience because those are
the two Superman figures within their
universes and I'm I'm really surprised
that they put those two in the same game
yeah yeah man to see what that would
even uh come to also Peacemaker John
Cena there too get his ass whooped
easily
it's just cool that the fatalities
themselves are fatalities that actually
cuz a lot of times when you when you do
the fatalities of the adaptations when
you take these these uh movie or TV show
characters and put them in Mortal Kombat
you have to really invent something we
haven't seen yeah and for their
fatalities they're just pulling from the
show yeah I like he that's literally the
end of one episode when he crushes that
guy's skull yeah that the train thing is
one of the most memorable moments you
know so comic apparently that's
something stly I think that's so cool
though that the fatalities themselves
are are just pulled directly from the
series itself instead of like and I
think that's like even more of a of a
dream come true in some ways you know I
there's a lot of really great ways to do
it and who knows who knows maybe they'll
crossover Mortal Kombat into Invincible
um one of these days actually you know
would not mind that it would be very
cool but you know what and also on
Mortal Kombats level what a great way to
just even if you're not into Mortal
Kombat you're probably like well I want
to play this I want to try it
out it's great marketing gimmick an
amazing marketing um it's cool because
we didn't see omn man return in the
trailer for invincible season 2 we did
not but he's here and it's JK Simmons
apparently I just looked it uh on the
description box uh that's neat all
righty guys what did you think about
this trailer leave your thoughts down
below uh I had a great time watching
this one Aaron what would you rate this
trailer uh 10 out of 10 10 out of 10 for
sure man that was amazing that was
amazing I feel bad I'm missing on all
these Mortal Kombat trailers but this
one felt very special yeah I agree I
loved it leave your thoughts Down Below
guys uh we will talk with all of you
guys very soon and also watch our
Invincible season 2 trailer peace out
reject
[Music]
Nation